Hello and welcome to my second video.
This has been pushed back and I'm a
blogger now.
The reason I'm doing another one,
actually it's because I had an idea.
Here's my thinking.
I'm a nerdfighter and a writer under
fighting writer,
a nerd writer watch.
That's almost a w.
So I am going to answer the Youtube
survey,
but first I wanted to say
congratulations to Maureen Johnson and
the name of the star.
It's fantastic to get published.
Regulations.
Boring.
I'm going to find your book and buy it.
Well,
my first kiss was in a tree house when I
was nine years old.
I was playing truth or dare with a bunch
of people and someone dared,
a girl named Erica to kiss me and she
did and that was my first kiss and I
couldn't fucking believe it.
Casual clothing,
I don't know.
Everything I wear is pretty casual.
I get most of it from the gap,
so probably $60,
99.
Really?
I didn't know what I wanted to be when I
was a kid.
I was always told that it would be an
engineer.
Like my dad.
I was always good at science and math,
but I never liked him.
I liked history and literature.
Eventually I decided I wanted to be a
filmmaker.
By that time I was already 17 years old.
Does that count?
I'm really glad you asked about school
friends because these are the most
important people in my life.
I'm a writer so I really could be
anywhere in the world,
but I choose to be in Los Angeles
because my friends are here.
That's the reason.
It's the only thing in my life that I
built that I think is worth preserving.
Friendship is certainly something that
you built over time.
It's work.
I love these guys and girls and if they
weren't Siberia,
that's right.
Beat by the girl George.
If I had a guy orpheus that will always
push and push,
that would be a good name to zillow.
500 to answer the survey next,
but he's my only subscribers so far.
I love Ucla.
Thank you so much.